- Hello, this is Priya Natarajan,
the current director of the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities.
I am utterly delighted to invite you all
to a fantastic talk today
that's part of our "Mapping
as Knowing" lecture series
that's been ongoing for a couple of years.
The title of our talk today is
Mapping a Polycentric
History of Renaissance Sound,
and our speaker is
professor Victor Coelho.
Before we start and I give a
fitting introduction to Victor,
I would first like to
thank our benefactors,
Mr. And Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
who I think are in
attendance this afternoon.
They have supported a host of
interdisciplinary activities
at Yale and the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities
is one of the flagship programs
that they've supported.
We are really benefiting
from their generosity.
So I also want to remind everyone
that we are recording this
event as per usual now,
and that all participants will therefore
have to have their videos muted
for the duration of the talk.
And please feel free to submit
your questions at any time
in the Q and A feature.
We will tackle them at the end of the talk
and Dr. Ty Kamp or I will read them out
for the speaker at the end of the talk.
Our wonderful speaker today
is one of a preeminent musicologist
who also happens to be a
performer, Victor Coelho.
He's the professor of music
and director of the Center
for Early Music Studies
at Boston University.
He specializes in 16th and
17th century Italian music,
as well as popular music.
His areas of research include Renaissance
and baroque instrumental styles,
popular music,
interdisciplinary approaches,
and cross-cultural perspectives.
As a specialist on popular music,
he's interested in blues, rock history,
improvisation and performance
more generally and broadly,
and appears regularly in
digital and print media.
As of 2017 Victor is also
president of the Saturday Club,
founded by Ralph Waldo
Emerson in Boston in 1855.
That is where I had the pleasure
and the honor of meeting him first.
He has held several visiting appointments,
at the University of Wisconsin-Madison,
the Ecole Normale Supérieure in Paris
and Cornell University.
He was also a visiting professor
at Villa I Tatti in Florence
and he also taught at
the university of Calgary
where he was named University Professor.
Prior to taking up as the director
of the early music study center at BU
he was the associate provost
for undergraduate education.
He was also the principal author
of the university's "One BU" report
on undergraduate education.
So as you can see, he has
several important commitments,
both to music, to pedagogy
and academia in general.
He's the author of many books
that include, "Instrumentalists
and Renaissance Culture",
published by Cambridge,
Music and Science in the Age of Galileo,
which is an absolutely fascinating book.
The Manuscript Sources of
17th-Century Italian Lute Music,
and the Cambridge Companion to the Guitar,
Cambridge companion to the Rolling Stones.
He is the lutenist and co-director
of the early music group II Furioso
and his recordings appear
on the Stradivarius
and Toccata Classic labels.
He tours regularly as a blues guitarist
with the Rooster Blues Band.
So without much further ado, I would like
to turn the podium over,
the virtual podium over.
I wish you could be here Victor in person
but we are delighted regardless.
Let me turn over to Victor for his talk,
Mapping a Polycentric
History of Renaissance Sound.
- Thank you very much Priya
and thank you Ty, it's
a pleasure to be here.
We had started this conversation
about appearing on the series in 2020
and in March 2020 when
I was supposed to come,
that was when everything locked down.
Next year they wondered
whether I would come
for a zoom meeting, a
zoom talk and I said,
well, I'd like to bring
an instrument or two,
so it doesn't really work on zoom.
A few months ago, Priya
wrote and Ty wrote said,
" You can come live now
and we can offer you dinner
and come on the train."
and I said, that's great, I accept,
then two days later they said,
no, no, we can't have any visitors,
but by that time, I'd already committed.
So I just wanna show
how wily they are really
at the Franke center.
I'm pleased to be here
regardless of whether it's zoom.
And I figured out a way that
we can hear some music as well.
I'm gonna share the screen
and we can get going.
The mapping of the Metropolitan center
and its outlying periphery
is both geographically real
and historic construed.
The associations implied by these terms
have been highly
influential in the writing
of both art and music
histories of the Renaissance.
At its most influential level,
the terms have been deployed
in historical accounts
to control the borders of the field,
to make decisions about what
to admit and what to own it,
and to provide a accounting of history.
One that is fundamentally
narrated from the center,
often through qualitative comparisons
with the so-called periphery.
In a famous statement by
the British art historian,
Kenneth Clark,
the center was the place
for the creation of art
leading to that style
becoming the dominant one.
It is metropolitan at its center,
but as it began to spread
out to the periphery,
it becomes more provincial.
In short, a style does
not develop universally
over a region.
It is the metropole,
a single unit that
stimulates its progression.
This view was a point of departure
for two highly influential articles
by the Italian historians Carlo Ginzburg
and Enrico Castelnuovo
who did not see a predictable
transmission of style
from the center to the periphery,
but rather the emergence
of a power dynamic
between the two areas in which the
so-called rich-heartedness,
this is their word,
of the periphery is a
rejection of innovation
and resistance to the center.
In the field of Renaissance musicology,
the notion of center and periphery
has essentially guided the manner
in which we map music history
from the early 15th century
to around 1600.
It is a story of courtly centers
of patronage like Ferrara
or ecclesiastical
institutions like the Vatican,
rarely venturing further
out into domestic music.
The provinces or cities in
the Venito not named Venice
or ones in Lombardy, not named Milan.
This model has effectively
subordinated entire repertories,
even urban ones like
urban instrumental music.
It has been used to ensure
the primacy of notated
so-called permanent works
over improvisational
so-called evanescent pieces,
even though improvisation was
one of the central techniques
used to teach composition in
the 15th and 16th centuries.
And the center periphery
model has also been used
to prioritize certain regions of activity.
Most notably courtly and
urban ecclesiastical cultures.
In this talk, I will suggest a revision
to the notion of center and periphery
by offering a new map of
Renaissance music history,
based on the concept of polycentricity
in which many centers can
operate simultaneously
characterized by both conformity
as well as individual and local styles,
both written and unwritten,
vocal or instrumental.
I will focus on three case studies.
The first is on the 16th
century Dutch composer,
Clemens non Papa in order to show
how the dominant center periphery model
in Renaissance musicology has affected
the reception of his work.
I will then move to a case
study about instrumental music,
which provides an excellent model
for a polycentric approach.
And my third example,
I will suggest how a polycentric approach
can even be influential in editorial work
through the example of
a new complete edition
of the works of the 16th century lutenist
Francesco da Milano,
that I've recently begun.
The Renaissance composer Jacobus Clemens
known by his contemporaries
as Clemens non Papa.
In other words, Clemens not the Pope
as if anyone would've
mistaken him on the street
as the reigning Pope
Clement the seventh, Medici.
Was born in the Netherlands around 1515,
and became one of the best known
and most influential
composers of the 16th century.
But his music is barely known today,
even to specialists of the period.
Clemens has barely given a name check
in the standard histories
of reference works.
It is rare as well to hear his
music performed or recorded
outside of a few pieces, even
by musicians who specialize
in this period and try to
explore many uncharted areas
of the 16th century repertoire.
Clement's contemporaries did
not see it this way however,
and this is an important
consideration that should push us
to revise the manner in which we map
our Renaissance music histories.
He composed an astonishing amount
in every major genre of Renaissance music,
mass, motet, French chanson.
And in compliance with the reformation
he composed over 100
Psalm settings in Dutch.
His music sees us vividly
on the texts he chose
in order to create sounds
scapes of drama and depth.
In addition, his work
was arranged repeatedly
by instrumentalists, lutenists
and wind bands mostly
who not only extended his fame all the way
to the end of the 16th century
by their many versions,
mainly for lute of his vocal music,
but also dispersed his music for a rainbow
of different classes of musicians,
civic wind bands, lutenists, *The Waylors.
Lutenists in Spain played
a similar instrument,
keyboard players, professionals,
and amateurs throughout Europe.
So here is a composer who
achieved considerable fame
in his day, but of whose
vast musical output
numbering over 500 works,
there's only faint familiarity
by Renaissance
musicologists and performers
outside of a few dozen pieces.
Then there is the problem of transmission.
His music survives in many formats,
printed and manuscript
sources in Dutch, Latin,
and French in many
different types of notation.
And we must consider not only the pieces
that he wrote himself, but also
the hundreds of arrangements
made of his music by other musicians,
which introduced one of
the central blind spots
of Renaissance musicology
that I will return to later.
In short, his considerable output
has yet to receive systematic
and consistent attention
and overlooking that would be
inconceivable in art history
for a painter that was
so prolific, popular
and whose work remained in
the rotation for decades.
Nevertheless, one wonders how Clemens
whose works were standards
on the Hip Parade
of the 16th century, is a
mere dot, a gas station icon
plotted on the accepted
map of Renaissance music.
There are several reasons for this.
The first is a conventional
but increasingly problematic
map-oriented history of Renaissance music.
In this account, the
central musical language
of the Renaissance
develops from about 1420
to around 1477 with composers
born and musically trained
in what was then northern Burgundy
and what is now the area
comprising Northern France
and Southern Belgium.
This musical language, its genres
and its compositional practices
were then transmitted south
over the Alps through the
circulation of manuscripts,
but more importantly by the recruitment
of many of these Burgundian composers
by Italian patrons to
cities like Milan, Ferrara,
Florence, Rome and to some degree Venice.
In these mostly Ducal cities
led by a ruling family
considerable economic
resources were devoted
to this recruitment of
northern composers and singers.
The assembling of choirs,
the training of musicians,
the production of manuscripts,
and for the benefits
normally provided to those
elite pro-Gandhian musicians
now in their employ, a
salary, lodging, horse,
wine, wheat and grain and
very often a generous pension.
Few of these composers
remain in Italy for good
and benefiting from the fierce competition
among patrons for their musical services,
most of these made periodic
returns to the north.
They accepted positions along the way
and added more landmarks
to the historical map
as they personally transmitted their music
along their travel groups
and composed new works
that were often aligned with
local musical traditions
or honored particular patrons.
The travels of Josquin des Prez,
easily the most famous
composer of this period
and the first one to
achieve international fame,
offers a case in point.
Josquin is born in 1450 up
here in Northern France.
By 1477, we find him in Aix-en-Provence
working for the Duke René of Anjou.
In 1484, we find him working
for the Sforza Dukes in Milan.
There's a reference to him
working in Hungary in 1485.
A reference that is quite
persuasive actually.
In 1489, he accepts a
position with the papal court.
He returns to France working
for Louis the 12th in Paris,
In 1503 we find him in the
estate court in Ferrara
and from 1504 to 1521, he
returns close to his birthplace
in *Cool Bay, Northern France,
where he remained until his death.
But even then he was
directing the circulation
of his manuscripts throughout Europe,
and almost had a kind of individual
manuscript production organization.
This gives you a good idea
of the types of travels
of a famous composer in Italy many times,
but then finding other positions as well.
With Italian courts now acknowledged
as the main musical centers
in the 16th century,
the north retreats into
musicological periphery,
carrying Clemens with it.
Clemens was born somewhere
in Flanders and even though
hardly any biographical
information survives,
he does not seem to have
ventured far from home
unlike many of his
remarkable contemporaries.
Letters suggest that
he became unemployable
because he was often or even mostly drunk.
He seems to have lurched from job to job.
Maybe this is why he's
known as Clemens non Papa
perhaps after he was drinking,
he put on papal clothing
and walked down the street
from tavern to tavern.
From beginning with a position in Bruges,
he bounced around several smaller cities,
but he was successful in the
world of publishing music
and writing works that had
immediate and lasting appeal
in French, Latin and Dutch.
In addition to the way
that the musicological
historical mapping cramped
Clemens' place in music history,
a second reason is a result
of another kind of mapping.
One that involves time, chronology
and the notion of progress.
An unfortunate but durable
musicological narrative
of 16th century musical progress,
places Clemens historically
within a distinct group
of so-called post Josquin,
quote unquote composers.
Sentencing him to a transitional
period of music history
that was characterized not
by innovation and craft,
but by playing to the demands
of the commercial market
during this first boom age of printing
and by an extended formalistic application
of the Renaissance contrapuntal technique
of what's called pervasive imitation.
Following, but never succeeding Josquin,
this group of so-called
post-Josquin composers
generally appear as a lost generation.
So Clemens is born between 1510 and 1515,
Josquin dies in 1521,
But following Josquin's death,
he becomes more famous than ever.
We have this Josquin afterglow
that continues well into the 1560s
in which, Josquin's catalog of works
increases exponentially
mostly by misattributions
or people wanting to place their music
under the name of Josquin.
But because of Josquin's
enormous popularity
during this period,
the composers who were
contemporary in this period,
were placed by musicologists
in what's called the post-Josquin period.
So they exist in the time of
the same Josquin afterglow.
Clemens dies in 1555,
but that is by no means
when Clemens' music also came to an end.
In the 1560s, the next great,
as far as musicology is concerned,
composer after Josquin was Palestrina
and Palestrina dominates
this age of the 1560s.
And again, it further
cramps Clemens' career
within this post-Josquin generation.
But the arrangements of
Clemens' music reach a peak,
starting almost 10 years after his death
and lasting for another 20 years.
There's an enormous amount
of arrangements of Clemens
as instrumentalists contemporize his music
for the last few decades
of the 16th century.
So Clemens was essentially
part of a lost generation
who essentially kept the seat warm
for the great counter
reformation composers,
Palestrina and *Lawzut.
The aesthetic quality of Clemens' output
became and remains grossly undervalued
in this pervasive and
discontinuous historical narrative.
One that only took into
account his sacred music,
not the larger impact his music had
through printing and as a
source for the arrangements
by other musicians.
As an example, one does not
need to look any further
than the discussion of
Clemens in Gustave Reese's
"Music in the Renaissance" of 1954
and subsequently revised in 1959.
The foundational text about
Renaissance music history
in English equal in importance
to Frederick Hart's book
on Italian Renaissance art.
Reese discusses Clemens
in a post Josquin chapter
tellingly subtitled "Richafort
and some lesser men."
a group that includes Clemens.
Reese drew the map of Renaissance music
into two large geographical areas.
The first focused on the
central musical language
of the 15th and 16th centuries,
geographically positioned
exclusively in Burgundy and Italy.
The second which he called
music of other lands,
lumped together everything
and everybody else
in England, Spain, Germany
and Eastern Europe.
Reese's division of history reminds us
of Saul Steinberg's famous
1976 New Yorker cartoon
of the way new yorkers view their city
against the rest of the world.
The notions of central and peripheral
are clearly embedded here,
both with Reese and Steinberg,
as well as the problems of this division.
Major composers that we recognize
like Victoria, Telles, Bird and Alan
are all extracurricular
to Reese's core language
despite their connections
however brief, to the center.
Chronologically the Renaissance
is also divided by Reese
into two further periods.
The early Renaissance,
beginning in the early years
of the 15th century and
the late Renaissance
extending to the 16th century
and to the early years of the 17th.
Reese offers a substantial
often detailed discussion
of Clemens' music, more so
than any other Renaissance
music history to date,
but it's placing of Clemens in a long wake
of post Josquin followers,
created for the composer
a subordinate position
that has both endured
and shaped the historical
narrative of the period.
In another much more recent
text on Renaissance music
by the Reese students, *Alan
Atlas, which is on the screen,
a remarkable book, this
is not on the screen.
A remarkable book in many
ways that is full of insights.
He even wonders whether we
should call Clemens' period,
the no name generation.
One of the most eminent
musicologists of the period,
Richard Taruskin in a
rare act of compliance
with other existing musicological opinion,
also hangs Clemens in
the post-Josquin closet.
Clemens illustrates how
the history, geography
and travel of Renaissance music
need to be scrutinized
and aligned more closely.
Clemens' life runs contrary
to what we've accepted
about Renaissance music history,
the center, and the periphery,
the traditional patterns of
influence and transmission,
basically the conventional
geomatics of history.
He did not travel far from his home
and he was not part of the
Burgundian Italian map,
he was therefore excluded
from consideration.
He came after Josquin
and before Palestrina
and remained in an area that
was not deemed progressive
as the musicological
focus turned to Italy.
In order to show how inaccurate
this assessment is of Clemens,
let us look at the wide
geographic dispersion
of one of his songs.
Not the song itself in its
original version for voices,
but by the instrumental arrangements
of this piece made by other
musicians of the 16th century.
The first one appearing in print in 1545.
The song appears first in 1545,
and the arrangements reveal the
long popularity of this work
and how this music got into the hands
of many need different types of players,
themselves creating arrangements
for yet other audiences throughout Europe.
This is from a manuscript in *Grand pres
which contains chanson, French chansons
by a number of composers.
You see *Gisa Lamb here
and, Claude and Richafort,
and then right in the box
you'll see Clemens non Papa.
Entitled Je prens en Gré
the song is one of his most famous.
The beautiful handling of texts,
and the syntactical
connections between texts
rhythms and musical rhythms.
It's not surprising that Je prens en Gré,
first published in 1543,
durably survived in the Hip Parade
for another half century,
due in large part to the many arrangements
that were made in French tablature,
Italian tablature, German lute tablature,
*Citrin tablature and for keyboard, harp,
organ and viola.
This on the screen is the
first lute arrangement
of this piece "Je prens
en gré" from Leuven
and it's an arrangement
in French lute tablature.
These instrumental versions
are essentially translations
of an original text or translations
of an original musical text
and like any translation
they point at new target audiences,
they arrive at new
geographical destinations.
And because these arrangements
are purely instrumental,
that is they expunge the
original French text.
They are able to cross
cultural and linguistic divides
throughout Europe.
Here's a transmission of
this song Je prends en gré
using the same map.
The original was published
in 1539 as a vocal piece,
but by 1547
we get this first publication for lute,
and the publisher,* Fales
not only publishes in 1547,
he publishes it again in 52 and
then nine years later in 63.
And then again in 71, and again in 82,
basically every 10 years, he's
coming out with this song.
This gives you an idea of the demand
that Fales thought this
song had in his time.
In 1547, we find a version
coming out in Trento in Italy
by another lutenist named Simon Ginskev.
1556, this song is published in Frankfurt,
in 1557 in Jaén in Spain.
1562 in Trieste by another Lutenist,
a blind lutenist from from Pulia
who settled in Trieste
named* Japlo Gorzanis.
In 1572 Strasbourg is published.
1576 back to Spain in Valladolid
1577, surprisingly it took a long time
for it to get to 1577 to
be published in Venice,
mainly because Venice's printing presses
were mostly publishing Italian madrigals.
In 1578 we have it published
for a Spanish lute in Madrid
and 1583 we have the last version
in the 16th century printed,
not even talking about
what might have existed
in manuscript, in Nuremberg.
Even though all these
instrumental arrangements
are different ranging
from highly ornamented
and flamboyant designs
to literal reproductions
of the musical texts' original song.
These versions dispel the
standard musicological notion
that Clemens's original
vocal piece in French
is the central source.
With these instrumental versions,
most of them made years
after Clemens' death
toiling in peripheral
outposts *off the main grid.
On the contrary, these arrangements map
a wide polycentric
geography of Clemens' song.
One that allows for a
multifocal and egalitarian view
of the work across
international boundaries.
They extend the distance
that a word can travel
from its point of origin,
from its composition as a vocal piece
to a transcription into
other regional notations,
leading to an adaptation
of the original work,
and finally a new performance
destined for different audiences
in diverse geographical locations.
To conclude this first case study,
confronting Clemens' brilliant music
from various musicological,
literary, historical
geographical and even
performance perspectives
forces us to question the
hierarchy and priority
that underlies the conventional
geographic boundaries
of Renaissance music.
It offers the chance to
scrutinize such notions
as so-called central and
peripheral traditions
and source types.
Greater and lesser
composers quote unquote,
singular versus plural
modes of performance
and the relationship
between original works
and their adaptations.
This leads me directly
into my second case study,
which I've already hinted at,
that is one major reason
for the exclusion of Clemens
from the narrative of Renaissance music.
Its that instrumental
arrangements of his work,
no matter how clearly they reveal
the wide international
dissemination of music,
as we have just seen, simply don't count.
Instrumental adaptations expand the map,
but because instrumental music
was a transitory and
highly volatile repertory,
much of an improvise,
before the 16th century
virtually all of it was either
improvised or memorized,
led to its neglect in modern
historical scholarship.
Primacy has always been
given to notated vocal music,
but this neglect would've
seemed unthinkable
for those who experienced
the soundscape of the time.
The reality is that any
history of this music
will need to develop a wide angle
rather than the narrowly focused
view we have used until now
to include the contributions of players
that were neither committed
exclusively to notation
nor bound to an authorized style of text
or style of performance.
Renaissance instrumental
music moves across
international and linguistic boundaries.
It is the product of both
autonomous composition
and arrangements of other pieces
often resulting in many
versions of the same work.
At the textual level,
the derivative versions
made by many types of musicians,
confront the critical
and philological methods
that have generally blueprinted
how Renaissance music
history has been studied.
Thus in examining this music,
one must resist the temptation
to prioritize pieces
and particular versions
since so many of them
are tightly interwoven
with culture and function across class.
We must remember how
much of the vocal music
of this period was arranged
by instrumentalists
and popularized and notated
instrumental versions.
For many listeners of the Renaissance,
these instrumental arrangements
were both the initial
and most frequent contact
of say Josquin's music much more
than for those who heard his music
during restricted services
in courtly chapels.
In addition to their use of
many well-known dance tunes
or songs and their
frequent roles as musicians
hired by the city,
instrumentalists also
played a practical role
in the geography of the city.
Trumpets sounding their instruments.
when the gates of the
city opened and closed.
Playing for civic processions,
announcing visitors and the like.
Returning to the Steinberg drawing,
it shows the traditional perspective
of Renaissance scholarship,
where the foreground
represents vocal music
cultivated at the institutional level,
whether court or cathedral
followed by everything
else in the distance.
Instrumental music permits us to create
a more detailed polycentric map
of Renaissance music so
that we can see exactly
what is on the other side.
We are aware of the enormous expenses
courtly chapels needed
to maintain a choir,
a scriptorium, and for
the training of musicians.
What about the music that
was heard everywhere else?
Nuremberg and Augsburg,
the largest most important
cities in Southern Germany,
but only half the size of say Bologna,
supported groups of maybe four musicians
who played for the city.
A reminder that the urban centers of Italy
were consistently much larger
than those of the north
and replete with funding for music.
Although the bulk of
archival data about musicians
is concerned mostly with
details of compensation
rather than what they actually played.
It remains difficult to produce
anything like a pie chart,
showing the relative expenditures
of a town like Nuremberg
on music.
However, for a small city like Wintzenheim
we can estimate that instrumental
music absorbed nearly 20%
of the city's disposable yearly budget,
which is considerable.
These smaller cities also tell us
about the social rank of musicians,
their origins, and their
personal geography.
For example, many musicians
from Augsburg and Nuremberg
found lucrative careers
in Florence and Ferrara.
Some came from very small villages,
the records of Augsburg
between 1450 and 1500,
indicate that several
musicians engaged by the city
during that time were from places
that must have had tiny populations,
200 or less in several cases.
Schrattenbach, remarkable cases
that have the minuscule
lower Bavarian town
of Schrattenbach near Augsburg,
which has a modern day
population of only just over 300.
It was probably distinctly
smaller in the 15th century.
This was the home of the *Ralph family
of musicians and instrument banquets.
In 1473, *Klaus Ralph
provided the city of Augsburg
with three pipers.
At this time Schrattenbach
was such an obscure place
that the Augsburg accountant inscribes,
felt it necessary to take
the extremely unusual step
of describing the location
in relation to its neighboring city,
when they listed the payment,
*paid four golden to RA in Schrattenbach
which is two miles from Kempten
and Kempten itself was one of the smallest
of the Imperial city.
These are just a few entertaining examples
from the archives, but the
point is that instrumental music
provides a more detailed, inclusive,
and frankly more accurate
modern map of Renaissance music
in which roads clearly
lead to other roads.
And we see a more detailed
network of influences,
backgrounds, and types
of musicians, context,
even the artisanal
infrastructure of music.
My final case study, the ideal goal
of arriving at a polycentric
map of Renaissance music
involves a current editorial project,
about the most important
lutenist of the 16th century,
Francesco da Milano, one
of the many lutenists
whose birthplace on the musical map
is embedded in his professional name,
Francesco Canova of Milan.
Similarly, there is Marco of Aquila,
Alberto of Ripa, Perino the Florentine,
Giovanni Maria or Crema, Lorenzo of Pavia,
Anibale the Padawan and so on.
Here, I will briefly introduce
how the polycentric model
which does not subordinate
the periphery to the center
can incorporate the
individual, the regional,
and even the idiosyncrasies a
performance into the addition.
Francesco the only musician
to share Michelangelo's epithet
of the divine, in divinum
I guess Bette Midler would be the third
was one of the most
highly esteemed musicians
of the 16th century and
the most influential
and important lutenist of the Renaissance.
Flourishing during a period
when the musical establishments
of most Italian courts
were dominated by northerners.
As we have noted earlier,
Francesco was the first
Italian born musician
of the Renaissance to achieve
truly international fame.
His music circulated widely in Europe
through prints anthologies
and manuscripts.
And by the beginning of the 17th century,
his works had achieved a classic sense
withstanding the dramatic
changes in musical style
and modifications to the instrument itself
that had rendered
most of the 16th century
lute repertory obsolete.
His music continued to appear in English
and continental sources,
a century after his death.
Making an addition of Francesco's music,
and this would be the second,
is notoriously complicated
because of the plurality
of source types and different
regional types of notation.
Authorized prints, anthologies,
student pedagogical books,
Florentine sources, Neapolitan
sources, Roman sources,
English sources, postumus sources,
incomplete sources, unreadable sources,
pieces copied from a print,
pieces copied from memory,
truncated pieces, ornamented pieces,
pieces clearly not by Francesco
but attributed to him.
Anonymous pieces that nevertheless
pass the test stylistcally,
to attribute them to Francesco, et cetera.
The sheer number of
versions that exist for us,
just a single piece can introduce
dozens of complex issues
regarding authenticity,
particularly among the 70 or so pieces
that appeared after his death.
And of the pieces for which
we are relatively secure
by Francesco, which version does one use?
The Neapolitan version that contains
lengthy ornamented passages
and unusual dissonances
or the more conservative,
but also more balanced,
*Indonesian version.
An attempt at a complete
addition was completed in 1970,
which resulted in
approximately 125 compositions
attributed to Francesco,
of which only 51 pieces
appeared during his lifetime.
Without reviewing the
merits, but more importantly,
the deficiencies of this addition
that have made it
imperative to do a new one,
suffice it to say that it was a product
of the rigid editorial
philosophy at Harvard
during the late 1960s,
in which choices about what
version to include or exclude
in an addition were made
by adopting the central
peripheral template.
Central sources being
those that were printed,
even if they contained works
of dubious authorships,
and there were many, and
manuscripts of elite pedigree
generally copied by a single scribe.
Peripheral ones like
those copied by students,
17th century sources and
prints like the Neapolitan one
I just described were not used
even if they contained superior readings.
In this addition, I will
employ a polycentric approach,
essentially advocating for the use
of many different types of sources
and benefiting from the
digital format of the addition
that will allow this.
When pieces have multiple versions,
that contain significant variants,
they will all be included
as a way to redraw
and expand the map to include
who actually played Francesco's music,
and to avoid the trappings
of the traditional center
and periphery model.
This means that not only are cultural,
regional, chronological
and textual differences
validated by their inclusion,
the variance documents
something that I believe
is critical to this project.
They reveal different
performances of the work
that took place over time and space
and how players incorporated
their individual musical
and technical abilities
across a wide geographical spectrum.
I thought we would hear
one piece by Francesco,
if this was live I was going
to come and play a piece.
I do have a recording of Francesco,
from a source that was used.
It's an important source that's
called the Siena lute book,
even though it is now housed in the Hague.
It's a manuscript version,
manuscript source,
and it contains one of Francesco's,
(speaks in foreign language)
So this is a recording I made,
I don't know, 15, 20 years ago, I think.
This is in Italian tablature
and I don't know how many
people read Italian tablature.
So I'll just use my cursor
as kind of the bouncing ball,
as we hear this piece.
It goes from here, all the way to here.
(soft lute music)
So in conclusion,
the active creating an
inclusive and connective network
of all musical practices,
sung, played, written and unwritten,
quickly reveals flaws in the
hierarchies and priorities
that have largely mapped the geography
of early modern music history.
But such *churny can also
offer the chance for revision
that is to move across a
historically constructed
and still not outdated
boundaries of central
and peripheral styles,
greater and lesser composers,
singular and plural modes of performance
notated and improvised practices
and the border between
original compositions
and their adaptations. Thank you.
- Thank you so much Victor
for the wonderful talk,
showing us how the sort of
disrupting this sort of dichotomy
of the center and the periphery,
and revealing to us that
geography has played
a really important role
in establishing the notion of tradition.
So if I may start with the first question.
I was curious with,
your three case studies
were really fascinating,
because of how, in the
case of Francesco da Milano
and the other, Marco da Aquila,
you showed how place is very
much part of the identity.
- Yeah
- And it also potentially,
I gather, sort of informs style
and even notation perhaps,
sort of a uniformity.
So I was curious, is there any kind of,
given that there are instrumental
modifications over time
and changes in notation,
is there any kind of universalism at all,
or does it not really
make sense to talk about,
sort of core ways in which
you could make connections
across time and across place?
- That's a good question.
I mean, there does seem to be
a kind of notion of progress
that takes place certainly
in certain centers in Italy.
Perhaps one model for a universalism
would be, towards the end of the century
when printers begin to
put together anthologies
and the anthology begins to then
bring together works that were popular,
that had circulated that
were clearly consumed
at many, many different levels.
These anthologies were very successful
when they came out and I
wonder whether that might be
where a lot of these composers
received sort of classic
status by being anthologized
similar to literature
in how poets and writers
become anthologized, those anthologies
become standard reading at institutions
and pretty soon that kind
of American literature
comes into focus, Northern
literature comes into focus
and that's how those things become mapped.
We don't pay enough attention
I think, to anthologies
but that I think would be one place
where I would start with this.
And they're both manuscript anthologies
and printed anthologies.
Manuscript ones are even more fascinating
because now we see a
person, an actual person.
In this case, the person, one of them
that I've studied as a young
17 year old Florentine,
who puts in his manuscript works
from the early 16th century
all the way to pieces of his time.
Works to sing, works to play,
works to play with his friends.
I mean, there's a very interesting aspect
of here's my personal
repertoire, here's my playlist.
This is my playlist and
playlists are a good analogy
because playlists do not
sit in one period of time,
they come from various places.
they're suggested, people are tagging it,
they're coming in, in
so many different ways.
And your playlist grows in
a very interesting fashion.
These magic mythologies are in a case
somewhat the same thing.
- That's intriguing, right?
That the anthologies might be
the place to kind of track.
So I had another question
about sort of the center
and the periphery right and I wonder,
you did not talk about any women composers
or women performers.
Are they just completely absent
from the sort of written record
though they existed, obviously?
- No, not at all in fact,
during the past few weeks,
we've learned about some major discoveries
by musicologist Lori Strauss
of a whole book of madrigals,
by a very well known or now
well known female composer,
and there are madrigal composers.
The problem, there were
lots of female lutenists
and in the book that I
wrote with Keith Polk,
we devote some time to
understanding the issue of gender
in terms of performance,
but professional roots
were pretty much blocked
where female musicians
tend to begin to thrive
in the courts of Mantua and Ferrara
during the late 16th century
as madrigal singers,
virtuoso madrigal singers
that put them on the doorstep to opera
in the 17th century.
We know about Isabella d'Este
and other women of means
who played the lute and composed music.
I don't think that I've ever found though,
a piece that could be securely attributed
to a female lutenist.
- So it was not that the women
were potentially part of the periphery.
We're still talking about like a very,
male composer, performer,
- Yeah and the repertories
associated with them, you know,
courtly repertories versus
non-courtly repertories.
Other than a few people
that I think were on the zoom call,
music for civic uses, music in cities,
was not very much studied,
a lot of that is improvised,
a lot of that is arranged.
And when you bring in
improvisation and arrangement,
those two verbs are fighting words
for many people because they
indicate a type of music
that was what I call
evanescent that's fleeting.
It's not permanent and arrangements
tend to be considered as corruptions of
or text that takes it out
of the composer's hands.
But there's no question
that composers understood
that their music was going to be arranged.
There are multiple versions
of their vocal music anyway.
So I think the periphery
is quite complicated,
it's both rural, it's classes of musicians
who are not elite musicians,
they come from families
that have been trumpeters
for many generations
or lutenists, they're lute makers,
there's a huge infrastructure
of instrument makers
that we often don't consider that
especially in Venice,
The periphery contains,
well what used to be called a periphery,
(Victor mumbles)
contains all of that material.
Instrumental music in general
has been relegated to that in many ways.
- Yeah, go ahead Ty
- I had a question if I may.
I wanted, and please I'm
showing my ignorance here,
I had studied flute and
piccolo classically for years,
but I am ignorant of tablature
as mentioned specifically
Italian tablature
so forgive me.
Would you explain it a bit more?
It seems to be based more
on a numbering system,
I'm used to more traditional notes.
- Yeah I mean, we still
use tablature all the time,
if you go on the internet and look for
the tablatures to Hotel California,
you'll get 20 of them all wrong.
So let's put up the *Fales here.
- Yeah, that'd be great.
- This would be the clearest one.
- Wondering about that.
- So this is called French tablature
and the lines that go across
from from left to right
are not staff lines those
are the strings of the lute,
one, two, three, four, five,
there's five here, and then he'll put,
there are six strings on the lute,
so he has to put the letters,
for the bottom string below the staff,
you can see where my cursor is here.
Okay, so this is the
top string of the lute,
a G, the second string a D here's an A,
there's an F there's a C, and
then there's a G down here,
which he doesn't indicate
mainly because he used
this font and he used this,
you know the blocks are
printing for many other uses.
I don't think he had a template
for six lines of tablature
so he just did five and
figured out the rest.
The letters indicate
where you put your fingers
on the frets.
So A means that you play the string open,
you don't have to fret anything
it's just an open string.
B means you put it on the first fret,
C means second fret D third, et cetera.
So when the letters are all piled up
one on top of each other, that's a cord.
That means that that
fourth string is open.
That D would be the third fret,
then you put your finger on the third fret
of the third string,
and you put your finger on the third fret
of the second string, and
you get actually an F chord.
And then he puts the rhythms up here.
Now the rhythms only give indication
of the fastest voice at any one time.
And so, right here, the
fastest voice at any one time
is what's going on in the top string.
And in other places like in
the piece that I played later,
see here.
Sometimes the fastest
notes are on the bottom.
So this is Italian tablature.
Italian tablature reverses everything
now there's no,
- Yeah. I was gonna ask about
the differences thank you.
- There's no letters now there's numbers.
- So now the A that we saw in
French tablature becomes zero.
So zero is the open string,
and one is the first fret.
The second is the second fret,
that makes a little bit more sense,
but that's not the only difference.
Now, the first string is
down here, the highest string
and the lowest string is up
here, so they reverse that.
So you have to kind of
learn both of these topics.
Then there's German tablature,
which assigns a unique
letter to every single fret
in every single note, typical.
So here's a good example
of the lowest voice
having all the rhythms.
So you just put the rhythm there
and you play all that stuff,
and then it goes to the top.
It's a visual depiction really,
of where you put your fingers
and the irony is that
tablature was invented
to make things easy
so people did not have
to read staff notation,
but it's exactly what has
prevented this repertory
from being widely known in
the musicological literature.
- And composers, Renaissance
composers in particular,
would've been conversant in
German, French and Italian.
- No, I don't think
anybody outside of Germany
was conversant in German.
That's why German tablature
faded by the early 17th century.
And what was left in the end?
Italian tablature kind of
fades in the early 18th,
what was left was French,
It was French in the end.
Very good question, those are good ones.
- So I actually have
another question, which is,
so Victor, when really does
the pattern of patronage
say for lute music
change from the court
and the church to more
music for the masses, or
was that always there?
- I don't think lutes
were music for the masses,
it's still the 1%.
Or the middle class by the 16th century.
The shift from the lute
to the Spanish guitar
there, you're getting,
then they're saying though,
all the barbers play them and
it becomes very easy to play.
And then you get a huge, huge difference
in terms of class of players.
But that takes us to
the early 17th century
and that's taking place in Spain
and in other parts of Italy.
But the lute remains, a
noble courtly instrument.
it remains a thing for
well educated youth.
It doesn't seem to have had
a kind of association with brothels
or the kinds of things that we see
with the guitar and other instruments.
You know, you look at
all the broil paintings,
you'll never see a lute
you'll see bagpipes and
you'll see things like that.
- Since you are interested
in cross-cultural musical influences,
are there versions of the lute
that are played around the world?
- So that's where it changes
and that's another problem
about the center periphery
it's that, when I was a graduate student,
you would've committed academic suicide
by saying that you wanna
study new world music
that was exported from
Spain or what I did in Goa
and looking at Portuguese music
that ended up in Goa India.
But that is a huge, huge
trove of information that's there.
And the first boats that came
to India carried instruments,
they had small portable organs.
That's what led these to
the harmonium in the end,
these organs that we call portative,
these tiny small little ones
that you can place on a table, which are,
you can see in many medieval portraits,
those are some of the
instruments that were used
to accompany chant when
they had mass on the boats.
And when they came to India
and they set up churches,
they brought those instruments.
Probably the English were the ones
who were very influential
in the organ becoming
associated with the harmonium.
But the harmonium was
essentially a portative organ.
That's probably one of the
only fixed pitch instruments
in India.
All the other ones are variable pitch.
- But in terms of motifs
and actual composition,
content of composition
and sort of structure
are cross-cultural influences discernible?
Did the mixture of cultures in Spain
in the 12th, 13th, 14th
centuries with the *Moores,
did that actually have
impact on these traditions?
- Yeah, I think that,
when you have, for example,
in the new world polyphony,
what's interesting is
the choice of the texts,
liturgical texts, that
they venerate saints,
that were particularly
venerated among new Catholics,
newly baptized Catholics, et cetera,
those are the ones that are just,
which are very different
from the types of saints
that, you know, might have
written texts for in...
- What about the sounds
themselves, the sounds themselves?
- So in India, we have a few manuscripts,
but they're all from convents.
They're all written for very high voices
and they tend to be all dedicated
to St. Michael the protector.
So there's that,
whether that lets us know
about particularly indigenous qualities,
that it's not clear because
these are written texts.
So the only thing would be
the texts themselves, the high voices,
because they're convents
and we don't have any written record
of the syncretic music that
was very much part of Goa,
around the 1560s and 70s
before the council of Trent
and other bodies pretty
much shut that down,
but there was a lot of
syncretic music making
and the archive show
*Shahamelas which are shams
violas, *darcos, or bowed
stringed instruments,
and instruments of the land,
there was that as well.
So there would've been, I think,
an indigenous quality to music making
within these institutions,
but there's no musical record
of those, unfortunately.
- So for example the
Indian *older traditions
musical traditions,
seem to have appeared quite independently,
so music and north Indian classical music.
But the argument is made
that the forms of music,
the forms of north Indian classical music,
like the ghazal
and these are very informed
by poetry and Persian.
- But these are Urdu
texts that go very, very,
very far back, yeah, exactly.
The question I always
have with Indian music
is performance, you know,
does Harry *Patrasia,
is he playing a style that
is 100 or 200 years old,
or is he playing a style that has somehow
been frozen from 400 years ago?
- I think the argument is often made,
when people talk about the difference
between Indian classical
music and other traditions
is that there isn't as
much room for improvisation
in Indian traditions, right.
- We're in Indian traditions
or outside of Indian traditions.
- Outside of Indian traditions.
- I've heard that in there
that is one of the things
that has been eliminated
from the writings about Renaissance music.
How do you talk about 15th
century instrumental music?
I mean, my colleague, Keith
Polk, I think he's on the call
and I devote a fair amount of space
in our most recent book.
You have to work your way back sometimes.
We have a source that might
reflect these traditions,
but we have enough theoretical evidence
about how they improvised and how they,
you know, you went from
one voice or two voices,
to three voices, to
eventually four voices.
Improvisation is a factor that's important
all the way through the
end of the 18th century.
And so while we recognize that now
for performance of the 15th
and 16th centuries and 17th,
we're now starting to recognize
that for more and more so
for performance of the 18th
and 19th century music.
But no, this new question on improvisation
is that blind spot in musicology,
Renaissance musicology.
- Unrelated question
Victor, how illustrated
were the tablature musical scores?
There was an earlier, I
think the first musical piece
he played, looked like it
had some illustrations on it.
I mean were these richly
illustrated or not maybe?
- Some were, the ones that were
illustrated were ones that,
the owner wanted to keep for posterity.
A good example is one that
I've just been working on,
hold on, it says loading here,
that I've just been working on.
This manuscript
this in the Newberry library,
this is a manuscript
written by a Venetian,
a nobleman from *Dreshya
and he had an artist
illustrate this manuscript.
- So even if it was lost,
if it had become lost,
somebody would keep it for posterity.
- But this is unusual.
Rarely are Renaissance lute manuscripts
given to a professional copyist
or a scriptorium or an illustrator.
This is unusual for many reasons
and I've done a study of
the images in this book,
but this might be one of the only ones.
There's a few in the 17th
century when they were engraved
but as far as my script
says, you can see this,
the birth of Adonis,
coming out of the tree.
So there's all these classical
references to these things.
They tend to be right at the
very beginnings of every piece,
and then later on the animals
start attacking each other.
You see a lot of these kinds of,
this decoration that you
find in Venetian books
or* automated books, all this kinda stuff.
So there's a strong
influence from the Venetian,
*Arabasks, I think is what they're called
from that tradition.
Good, good question.
- This is gorgeous, wow, very gorgeous.
I feel bad that we've been
monopolizing the entire time
for questions.
Let's wait and see if
there are any questions
from the audience, please
go ahead and type them,
in the Q and A.
I could keep asking trying to understand,
this stuff is so, so fascinating.
So I guess while we wait for someone else
to muster up courage
to type up a question,
I would like to sort of continue.
You showed a lot of
these manuscripts, right?
So what, in modern day
music, what do you think,
how should we preserve our
musical traditions now?
- Well, they're all digital.
How do you preserve the actual item
or preserve the traditions,
say, a tradition that in a village
that's rapidly being modernized
or something like that?
- Both, I mean, both really, right.
You have a recording that is digital.
But the text, the actual
musical scoring of it and so on,
I mean, just scanned copies.
Velom has survived quite well.
- It's not much anymore.
I think that the large
collections in Europe
have been on a project of
digitizing now for 20 years
and during the pandemic,
it was remarkable to see
how I could continue my work
by being able to get complete
full text manuscripts
from most of the major libraries.
There's enormous amount
of government funding,
I've just signed off as a reviewer
for a very large one in Germany,
that's probably the largest
one that I've ever seen,
with the Austrian National Library in tow
and things like that, but that is a way,
and those things are searchable.
There's a lot of
metadata, there's tagging,
it's easy to burn through
those collections,
with questions and try to find stuff.
So in that sense, it's very
good to have those digitized
because for analytical work,
it becomes much, much easier.
But in the day,
I mean, I looked at every
single one of these manuscripts
by hand, and most of
my colleagues did too,
there was no other way.
Or you looked at it on microfilm,
those days are over.
As far as the musical
traditions themselves,
I mean the older, older
history of ethnic musicology
was that you would try to
preserve these traditions,
but by preserving them,
you're also recording them
and you're creating a kind of intrusion.
Alan Lomax recorded all
of those blues musicians
in the south, country blues players,
musicologists went to
Bali, they went to India,
recorded and recorded.
And then as tourism encroaches,
and you see some of these villages
now stopping to play music
and those musicians who
played village music
are now playing in the hotels.
You could decry that and say, wow,
this is so disappointing.
But what you're seeing is
a transformative aspect
of how music is being transformed.
Goa's another great example.
The whole coastline is
dotted with five star hotels
and you go in there and you find people
singing in konkani,
traditional konkani songs,
you know, for tourists.
The interest now is how
those things have changed
from early recordings.
What we are finding out
is in places that play,
Golan instruments and things like that,
all these hotel players
are playing much faster
than they ever had before,
because they've gotta fit it in
for the people that arrive on the bus
where they're stopped at the hotel
to have some food and hear the show
and then go back on the
bus to the next event.
So everything has been transformed.
So in a sense, you have
the musicologists saying,
let it die,
and see how it see how
it plays itself out.
- Right. And see what
remains as a residue.
- Right. Rather than the
old, * alamirium concept
of the knight on the white horse,
who's gonna come in and
record and save everyone.
That's the white night theory.
- Great, thank you so much.
I think Ty,
did you have any last
questions before we wrap up?
- I was curious, I'm not sure if this
is historically correct
but what, from what you
presented, flourished most
in the new world when it was found.
What kind of made it over?
Were there any, well,
- In India, they brought books of chants.
The early explorers brought books of chant
because they needed to
celebrate mass on the ship.
And when they got there and
they built a very early church
in St. Catherine's, which still exists
crumbling in old Goa.
By 1540, they were bringing in polyphony.
So this is a chant now with another voice.
I don't know what kind,
it's probably very simple,
two voice polyphony, and
they have a word for it.
*conto d'organo , singing over the organ,
so two voices versus
*conto chao which is chant.
So that's a big development there.
By the 17th century
mainstream Jesuit music,
because the Jesuits were in Goa.
Mainstream, Roman Jesuit
music from the Roman college
is being sung in Goa, mainstream.
Going the other way, there's a very large,
two very large collections in Mexico city
that are late 16th, early 17th
century, mainstream music.
But also containing some composers
that were trained in Mexico.
Some of the indigenous composers
That's been a very
important source for study,
There is a lot of travel,
this kind of music, all of it
required extensive training
and training requires an
extensive commitment of resources.
So in a sense in the end
you talk about India,
the Christian project
really did not survive.
- But not take off really...
- It didn't really, all the letters
that Xavier sent back to Rome
saying that he had baptized 10,000 people
on the coast and things like that,
he went to Kerala and
baptized another 5,000.
Those were all exaggerations.
- We do have one question in the Q and A
if I may read it out.
Was there any music
related to specific events,
historical figures or memories
that people could interpret
in their own ways?
- Well, there's a lot of music
that was written for specific events.
These would be what we have,
large events, institutional
events, coronation, weddings,
et cetera, weddings, and things like that.
We do see that music
begin to then trickle down
into the hands of domestic musicians.
So that's a good point and one example
would be Medici festival music,
these enormous pageant celebrations
with tons of pageantry,
which went on for weeks
and weeks at a time
when one of the Medici married somebody
from the Habsburg empire or
from the French empire or whatever.
Eventually that music
began to trickle down,
and I've traced a little
bit of how it was,
but it got into the hands
of domestic players,
people who were probably connected
with seven degrees of
separation from the court.
And then that music was arranged
and some of that music which
was originally for four voices
now appears for one
voice and *ludacontinum .
So that's what actually happens.
So that is a transformation,
a personal transformation
of a work for that person's own use.
- Great, we should probably
not detain you any longer
and thanks once again Victor
for the wonderful talk.
- I'll see you in May, yes.
- Yeah. I'll see you in May
and I'm really looking forward
to when we can welcome you to campus.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
Thank you very much and thank
you everyone for listening.
- Thank you Victor, thank you.
- I also want to say thanks to Dr. Ty Kamp
and Brian McEvoy for helping
us with the recording
and the recording should
be available online
fairly in short order within a week or so.
- Thank you.